it's great to be joined today by James
Underdown who is the founder and
director of the independent
investigations group based in Los
Angeles California they offer $100,000
prize to anyone who can show compelling
evidence of a paranormal or supernatural
power or event using controlled
scientific protocol we'll talk about
that in the second part of our interview
James you've done so many interesting
things with regard to the paranormal
psychic etc how did you first get into
this line of work well I mean I was the
I was appointed as the executive
director of the Center for inquiry so
that landed me in a world that dealt
with these sort of things right away but
I had an interest in it for a long time
before that when I was a kid I remember
going to see erich von Daniken speak
outside chicago he was one of wrote this
book called Chariots of the Gods and he
proposed that the earth had been visited
many times by alien alien creatures too
so I was interested in that and I
remembered some book about some book
called super learning that at the one of
the last chapters I think taught people
how to exercise their psychic powers so
I had a real interest in and stuff and
then when after I discovered skeptical
Inquirer magazine and started learning
about what was really going on with
these sorts of claims it kind of blew my
mind that all this stuff could sound so
plausible but not be so when I took a
job we actually decide I founded this
group the independent investigations
group so that people could get some
hands-on experience and look into some
of these things ourselves and one of
those areas is the concept of psychics
and you've actually appeared on the dr.
Phil show and you were presented to a
small audience as a so-called psychic
and then a so-called real psychic did
readings for the same group
and this really comes down to the skill
of cold reading right I mean talk about
how you prepared for that in your
experience doing that yeah well first of
all I love the fact that you keep saying
so-called because that's a good warning
for people when I originally said yes to
the dr. Phil show
I mean I'm perfectly able to you know go
and talk about the issues of weather
psychics exist or not but when they said
they asked us if there were ways to test
psychics for the purpose of the show and
I said yeah there are lots of different
ways and I started rattling off these
ways and they kept saying oh no no no
what we really want to do is have you or
somebody gave a reading and then
somebody else give a reading just as you
described and at the time I said yes I
was I had someone else in mind one of
the members of our group who is a very
experienced cold reader but that person
turned out not to be available for the
reading so I had to do it myself and I
had never done that before I mean I know
a little bit about how it's done and
everything but yeah it's one of those
things that you know takes a lot of
practice and the more you do it the
better you get at it so I mean I sort of
just reviewed everything I thought I
knew about how to do cold reading so by
the time I got to that little studio on
Monday morning I was Ellis as letty as I
was going to be and is it true that
after it was revealed that you were I
mean III I don't even know what to call
it but I call it just messing with
people and you didn't you don't really
think you're a psychic that a supposed
real psychic said no James is actually a
real psychic he's just bitter or
something like that I mean it did that
actually happen yeah that actually
happened on camera during the show and
oh my god I mean what do you say to that
yeah you know it's and it's funny too
because the people change their story
the people who I read are some of them
anyway
um some of them at least believe me I
three people cried during the course of
my reading I was posing as a medium who
was making contact with people's dead
relatives and friends and in the course
of my reading my first time ever reading
three people cried and even one of the
cat some of the stuff was cut out one of
the cameramen said yes I know exactly
what you're talking about all these
other things so it worked
at least a percentage of his people you
don't believe me but then when the time
for the shows to come and they had
already been told that I was faking it
they said well we didn't believe him in
the first place and we knew all along
that he wasn't as good as the other
person and I said well of course the
other person who did that had you know
thousands of readings under her belt of
course she's going to be better at it
but the fact is you believe the first
time or attic because it's mostly
because you wanted to believe this James
by the way your microphone is hitting
your shirt collar a little bit so just
be aware of that because it is it is
making some noise this isn't just
limited to psychic-type stuff you were
on The Oprah Winfrey Network they had
this miracle detective show and there
was a story of a supposed angelic
apparition which supposedly cured a 14
year old a severely disabled child at a
hospital in Charlotte North Carolina
so you were sent in there and and what
did it actually turn out was the reality
of that curing well the claim was when
this girl was in dire straits and the
family was was deciding whether or not
to pull her off her respirators helping
a Bri she had a collapsed lung and some
other issues in addition to being
severely disabled in other ways one that
when that decision was about to be made
they saw the nurses or somebody in the
room saw a
right image on the outside of the ICU
area so the doors going into the ICU
open and this sort of three lobe image
that look like a sort of looks like a an
angel appeared they took the girl off
the ventilator and she could breathe on
her own and she eventually got better
and so they attributed that light image
to the curing of the girl now there was
a couple problems with it first of all
they said that there were no it was an
interior hallway which is correct but
there were no light sources that could
have allowed for that light image to
appear on the monitor by the way they
took a picture of the monitor so we
could look at it in some detail to see
what it looked like and when I got there
we look to this hallway down just after
the entrance there and there was a
little sliver of opening between where
those doors were and an exterior window
which is very interesting and then I
pour CH initely I had some astronomer
friends I could call and I we found out
the direction of which way the building
was facing and we knew what time of the
year it was so I said where's the Sun
coming from on you know during this week
and sure enough it's coming right down
the pipe it's like exactly facing the
southwest direction where where it
needed to be to do that image and then
we came back to LA and in the course of
the show we recreated that hallway and
just stuck a theater light down there
commitment the Sun and sure enough that
it made almost exactly the same images
what appeared on the monitor so these
are a couple of the of the claims you've
worked on but you also do work when it
comes to pseudoscience claims consumer
products that may
claims that are not actually possible or
backed by evidence etc what is the sort
of overarching theme that you you tend
to find when looking at both
pseudoscience and sort of the medical
world product claims etc I mean how
would you sort of summarize that aspect
of your work now we try to focus on the
things that are making claims that are
there they're using the language of
science to sound legitimate but they are
making extraordinary claims that are
contrary to what our current scientific
knowledge says I'll give you a couple
examples one is the widely used product
of homeopathy yes it's very likely that
your homeopathic medicine in some cases
and the more seriously diluted cases
that you may not even get a single
molecule of the active ingredient
correct in your homeopathic ami Pathak
medicine so the physics of it alone but
without even talking about anything else
that physics of it alone suggests that
not only is not working but it couldn't
possibly work and then we see other
things I mean some of the stuff just
comes to our attention
I see pro athletes basketball players
football players baseball players
wearing certain necklaces around their
neck or wearing these Power Balance
bracelets and so one time Yahoo News
came to us and said you know we'd like
to test this and Olympic gymnast
Dominique Dawes showed up and so we
created a test that sought to find out
whether the power balance bracelet
itself made any difference in athletic
performance so we ran 16 people through
this obstacle course four times only
once did they have the actual Power
Balance bracelet on on each time they
wore
kind of bracelet and they never knew if
it was the actual power balance bracelet
or the facsimile so you know we wanted
to see if the scores got better when
they actually wore the real bracelet so
before in that case we didn't even go
into you know the physics and the
science of of whether it could work we
just wanted to see if it if it did work
and if it made a difference and so I
really went through the course four
times and there was absolutely no
difference between the fakes and the
real one surprise surprise all right
let's pick up the conversation there
we're speaking with James Underdown
founder and director of the independent
investigations group in LA we will
continue the conversation with him
tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation with
James Underdown who's the founder and
director of the independent
investigations group based in Los
Angeles California we've talked about
psychics we've talked about homeopathy
and so many other things let's talk now
James about this hundred thousand dollar
prize that is available through your
organization to anyone who can show
compelling evidence of a paranormal or
supernatural power or event using
controlled scientific protocol I think
this is interesting in a couple of ways
and some in my audience might know that
the James Randi Foundation has been
offering a million-dollar prize which
sounds to be pretty similar to what you
are sort of setting up here I have a
couple of questions and the first is
what do you define as controlled
scientific protocol and number two how
do you deal with inherently this sort of
reality that many people who believe in
the sorts of claims that you debunk will
say you can't really prove that it's not
true and the sort of complexity of
proving a negative inherently yeah well
I mean to start out with the controlled
environment that the point of all that
is to eliminate all the trickery
magicians
for instance or mentalists who are
knowingly doing a trick need a very they
need to be in control of their
environment because they're doing a
trick and they need to set certain
things up and
in order for them to cheat convincingly
they have to be in control of the
situation
all we're seeking to do is to eliminate
all the cheating aspects of it and let
it boil down to the actual skill or not
so for instance if we're we're testing a
telepath say we want to cut off all the
nodes of communication between the
sender and receiver of whatever they
claim to be sending across so we don't
want them to have transmitters in their
pocket we don't want them to be able to
use sound or visual cues or anything
else to communicate with the other
person that's all the control
environment means and what was the other
question was about well so part is sort
of just inherent difficulty of you know
you psychics are often asked there's a
million dollars available to you really
1.1 million right 1 million from James
Randi and another hundred thousand from
you if you can demonstrate in a
controlled environment that you really
are a psychic and when you ask psychics
suppose it's psychics why they haven't
done it they say I'm not in this to make
money or that's not how it works or
there's some such explanation but
there's an inherent complexity in the
difficulty of proving that someone is
not a psychic definitively is it there
well I would argue by saying you know
technically we are not by by proving
that one person cannot exhibit such a
skill technically we're not proving that
it's impossible but we're proving that
this person or demonstrating that this
person at this time cannot do it right
so yeah I mean all we're doing is time
after time after time showing that the
individuals who completely believe by
the way we have not had one person
trying to fake it people who are sincere
in their beliefs 100% of the time have
not been able to show these abilities
and how does that work I mean it tell us
a story of one person that came in
claiming to be able to do X and sort of
how it went
and maybe most interestingly how they
reacted at the end how did they explain
why they weren't able to pass the test
well I will give you one example two
guys took a bus from Tacoma Washington
all the way to Los Angeles to be tested
in a telepathic challenge now they said
that they could do I think it was
something like we could flip these are
just playing playing cards a regular
deck of playing cards they said they
could guess 47 out of 52 cards correctly
which by the way probability-wise
is off the charts it's in the gazillions
to one right be able to do that
unchecked alone so if we're doing our
luck alone if they can do it it would it
would look pretty good on their part and
by the way if also if you guess the same
card every time you're guaranteed of
getting at least one right but I got
zero right out of 52 and he was a little
bit funneled he was sort of couldn't
understand why it didn't happen and he
just kind of shrugged his shoulders and
then whatnots billions but it's at the
start I mean in other words what was
that guy doing in the privacy of his
home where he was guessing 47 out of 52
that would leave him so confused as to
why he all of a sudden couldn't do it
when he shows up in Los Angeles yeah
that's a great question and usually I
mean we always tell these people test
yourself at home first use this exact
same test that you're going to do for us
at home because if you can't do it at
home you're not going to be able to do
it in front of a bunch of strangers
either but I think what happens is you
know one of the classic things that we
skeptics always try to tell people is
you know a lot of times people remember
the hits and they forget the misses
you're standing in front of a bank of
elevators and you say that one's going
to open next and it opens next and you
say oh my god I have psychic ability or
it happens you know twice in a row or
something the next 40
times you do it or you know the next
half of the times whatever you forget
that you missed it and all you remember
is your successes so you get it in your
head that you're you have this ability
how do you test the psychic someone
comes in and we've done it in our studio
and we had a so-called psychic come in
and do a cold reading of a former
employee and end of me and it was just a
totally abortive display of no snow
skill even whatsoever never mind psychic
abilities but that wasn't a sort of
scientific or controlled test it was
just this person seems to be wildly
guessing and is wrong how do you go
about what are the conditions for
testing a psychic well it depends on
specifically what the psychic claims are
and they're all different and it's one
of our big jobs is to try to narrow
people down exactly what is it exactly
you say you can do can you predict the
future can you tell me something
specific about myself the way a lot of
the psychics operate who charge people
to come in their storefronts or whatever
is they just make lots and lots of
guesses and you know there are some
there's this technique called cold
reading I think you still there James
we're having a bit of a connection issue
where you're kind of bringing up can you
still hear me okay double leg is giving
the parents to consult a Don a little
fuzzy to them could have been me not had
a moment those internet business yeah I
think we're back James you were you were
talking about cold reading is where we
lost you so yeah cold reading is the
ability to give the impression that
someone is consulting with some outside
power to get this information but really
it's just a technique of making lots of
guesses using a certain language that
makes it sound like you're being right
even though you're sort of getting in an
ambivalent answer and it's reading the
physical appearance and reaction of a
person to know if you're on the right
track
in the process of your storytelling as
you're telling giving information so in
the case of a regular psychic reading
there's really a fair amount to know and
that's a little bit tougher to test
because there's so many different
versions of what psychics do and really
have to define it first before we could
come up with a path in your experience
James our psychics okay being unable to
see the person that they're reading
because that would do a lot as far as
the sort of constant reading of the
visual response from the person or will
they say no I need to be able to see the
person know there are plenty of them
that just do these things on the phone
and you don't need to I think it's a
help to be able to see someone you could
look at how someone's how someone
dresses or what sort of haircut they
have or even what color their skin is
might be able to help you give a better
reading yeah but it's certainly not
necessary I know a woman who gave $1,000
reading to someone on the phone and she
spent fifty five minutes just chattering
away and making literally hundreds of
guesses for the for the person and got
some of them right hey on a personal
level like I I'm I'm sceptical by Nature
and I've never seen demonstrated
evidence of psychic abilities but I'm
completely open to the possibility that
in five years ten years twenty thirty
years there may be something which would
fall under the umbrella of what we now
would consider to be psychic abilities
it would be demonstrated scientifically
and it would be by some mechanism that
we as humans don't yet understand but
could well exist it what's your sense of
the possibility of that uh uh it's
certainly possible I mean you know
science doesn't know everything about
everything so yes you have to open up
the slight possibility of that it
doesn't look like that's going to be the
case what's more likely going to be the
case and the things when we have to
watch out for is that someone will be
able to implant something into their
body
and be able to transfer information that
way or we're even finding this out and
you know with paraplegics and stuff
where you can wire like hardwire parts
of your brain and actually control
something that happens outside of you
which in a you know in a fuzzy sense
might be considered telekinetic ability
the ability to move something but it's
not really it's it's technology aided
but it doesn't look like the organic
parts of our body our brains
particularly have anything in them that
would allow such a thing to occur
James Underdown founder and director of
the independent investigations group
$100,000 available to you or anybody you
know if you can show compelling evidence
of a paranormal or supernatural power or
event under controlled protocol James a
real pleasure speaking with you today
the pleasures by Maude thanks for having
me on